this is a production of cornell
university
um so as rebecca highlighted my name is
jacqueline vince mcroberts
um i and i'm really excited to be here
today i wish i could physically be with
you guys
um my husband and i actually met at
cornell and it's just
just such a great um location just
beautiful campus and and we hope to be
there uh
sometime this summer to come and visit
um but what we really want to share
today is a little bit
about my personal story larry's personal
story
and then the bayer r d pipeline uh when
someone
asked me to introduce myself the first
thing though that i just always have to
start with is the fact that i grew up in
a military family we moved every
one to three years maryland was actually
like the last place that um we landed at
and that's where i
ultimately ended up going to uh college
as rebecca had highlighted
um so uh i thought i'd start there
because a lot of
um you know who i am today it was really
formed in my childhood along with the
rest of you guys out there
um but really it was this active
engagement that
my family had in the community that
really ingrained this desire to serve
and do meaningful work so when my mentor
there at st mary's college of maryland
um
pulled up a bulletin on his computer
screen that read usda needs breeders
i knew this was my call to action
because it just bundled my passion for
people
plants and the environment into this
food security focus
so i spent the next um six years uh
just about at cornell university earning
my phd in plant breeding and genetics
um like probably many of you who are on
the phone today and
afterwards joined a company committed to
helping farmers around the world
produce crops while efficiently using
resources so
i'll go into a little bit about my my
day job but before i do that i just want
to say that i've been able to kind of
keep up this passion for serving the
community
through our bayer business resource
groups that
have certain focuses so i was on the
leadership team of
women in science exchange and then um
more recently i've been on the
leadership team of
arise which was uh intended for african
and african descendants
um so through those opportunities i've
been able to
organize several events that uh provide
this leadership mastery business acumen
and other development
opportunities at bayer and then more
recently like really leveraging the fact
that i work for a big company
to go out into the broader community and
just continue to do
do good things so um well i'll probably
we'll be focusing on
uh the actual business part of um my
career i just want to say that there's
just a lot of opportunity
uh when you when you join the company to
continue to fulfill these other aspects
of
of who you are uh so i thought for
an audience with students thinking about
potential careers
it'd be helpful to see my career path to
date because i recall not having a ton
of visibility into industry careers
before really commencing on
onto my own so there's really just sort
of this black box
in front of me when i decided to join
i've been with bear now
for nearly eight years and have more or
less looked for a new role
or increased scope within the same role
every few years
i attribute that sort of um that sort of
timing mostly
towards the lifestyle growing up moving
every few years and consider myself
basically
program for change in that interval um i
can also share a bit
a bit about their fruition of that in my
graduate school career
because and rebecca was kinda and i were
kind of talking about that
before things got started but as i had
mentioned
as rebecca and my myself were both
mentioned that was those six years so
you know
i was probably getting antsy right
around that the three-year mark
but anyway um we can talk about that
during the the graduate school uh career
section
or sorry the the student session uh
later today
so my first role was in trade
integration
or ti as we um fondly think of it uh
landing in this particular part of the
business
was just really beneficial to me and
just kind of cool because in order to do
your
job well you needed to really be well
connected within biotech because you're
receiving new traits coming from them
within breeding because they're really
the ones developing the
uh the new lines that are coming through
and you're eventually handing off to
commercial development breeders to
to test and then also with latter parts
of the the um
the chain that i'll talk about uh the r
d pipeline that i'll talk about today
um because you're handing off material
to supply chain so they can continue to
increase for commercial production
reasons so
it was during this time that i was
really most proud of
some of the strong relationships that i
was able to build off-site
um with our hawaiian puerto rico team as
well as
folks that were in brazil and just this
cool opportunity to work
um remotely even before we were all
working remotely
and and we had this focus to continually
optimize
and deliver on the right products at the
right time and i took the opportunity to
lead teams and develop data science and
automation solutions to improve the
efficiency of the pipeline
so um into this next kind of section
here
quaranti after a little while and sorry
i didn't i didn't emphasize that since
my
phd work was in core and i went right
into corn at monsanto
and then um after a couple about a
couple years
uh there i decided to um take on a
leadership opportunity within the corn
space and then
corn was really working like this wild
oil machine
when i was asked to take over the
varietal ti pipeline that at that point
had like 39
um status on track and i know like you
don't really
realize when you're standing outside of
a business that like things can kind of
come to that point in these these big um
at these big large companies but but
they really do and i think that that's
when you have this cool opportunity to
just like
um stand up and take on the challenge
and face it and so
um was what was interesting about it was
that um
it required building more than anything
i think more than the technical
solutions it required building
relationships
trust and organizational organizational
transparency
and um this role really expanded my
exposure to some very passionate people
on crop team who are in charge of
developing our crop strategy
across um across our different functions
that i'll go into in a bit here
but the main uh the major difference um
really
between corn and varietal ti and my
experience was that the pipeline just
wasn't
operating well and um no one is asking
any questions when things are going well
and they're receiving their products but
um you get an awful lot of inquiries
when you're not producing what you're
supposed to be and so
it was during this time that i learned
the importance of pipeline transparency
and stakeholder communications and
continuing um
to to help people understand why is it
that um our particular program is so
uh so challenging so um after about
five years in ti i was really looking
for my next role
and while i knew i was passionate about
developing people i thought that this
was really good
time to further increase my exposure to
the business
and focus on developing particular skill
sets that would make me a better leader
that included
um things like developing strategies
managing product uh projects and leading
through influence so i just kind of took
um i wouldn't say a pause but i took
like a major like development
um leap or so uh and and
um it was also during this time that i
was kind of i was
kind of um developing on a personal
level too so i had my daughter during
this
time she's now um almost two years old
come
come here in april and uh so not only
was i
you know developing as a as an
individual outside of the workplace i
was also
focused on really making sure that i
just just stayed on top of
my work development as well and so um
moving to a strategic role in crop
efficiency within a new organization for
me now i had jumped over to plant
biotechnology
and focusing on the gene editing
technology which was really new to the
company at that time
was really this good opportunity to
learn how to lead through influence
because i was no longer the expert
i wasn't the one that could provide very
specific and you know instructions or
recommendations
um and and on top of that i don't have
any direct reports so you have to learn
entirely how to operate through uh
influence
so now um in three years into my current
role
and having discussions um on what that
next role might look like
so um just moving on here
a little bit to i think um what what you
guys will be the most excited about
uh is our bare crop science
um is really a sense of like why we are
in agriculture and bay aircraft science
and
and some detail about the r d pipeline
so today
larry and i want to provide a glimpse
into our trade and germplasm product
pipeline with a focus on
gene discovery editing precision
breeding and commercial deployment
and um one thing is for sure
that you know that i believe
these mega trends of a growing
population and pressure
on the ecosystem from climate change are
going to be very familiar to this
audience
but i really wanted to share this to
highlight why it was so important for me
to join a company
that aligned well with my mission um
personal mission and really like
personal values and
it really boils down to having some
fundamental desire
like that same fundamental desire that i
had before applying to the cornell plant
breeding program
and i think it's expressed well in
bayer's um
recent i would say uh updated vision
of health for all and hunger for none
so by 2050 there will be more than
2 billion additional people on the
planet requiring 50 percent more food
from the same agricultural footprint
upon which we're producing today
at the same time climate change is
leading to more volatile weather
and generally warmer conditions as you
all are are really familiar with
um so this comes at a cost experts
estimate that by 2050
we'll have lost 17 of our annual harvest
from our four
key crop groups these are coarse grains
oil seeds
wheat and rice from and that will really
be primarily from
climate change but on top of that when
you look at the combination of
population growth and a fixed
footprint of arable land this translates
to about
20 percent reduction in the arable land
uh per person by 2050
literally this means it will only have
about 1700 square meters of arable land
per person for food production
and for you soccer fans or parents out
there
that's about a quarter of a soccer field
per
person so at the most basic level this
means that
we need to be able to secure sufficient
supply of food while using our natural
resources more efficiently and
responsibly
and one thing that i learned um i think
one thing that has always stayed like
true north for me um having come out of
rebecca's lab
is just that concept trying to figure
out how to
um best use our natural resources most
most efficiently
um so this is the challenge that we face
and one that many
in this audience is passionate about i i
know that and i
and you know i i i know many of them are
a handful of the folks on the phone but
i'm just guessing
that this is the reason why you decided
to to join
um the plant breeding and genetics
program or one of the
the contributors the science is also
really cool
um so so this is uh not you know a
widely known challenge and it's one that
our company is really focused on
stepping up to
so a little bit about the how now
um bayer is an innovation company and
one thing that we've noticed is we've
looked
at how other companies invest is that we
we invest more on in general in our r d
than other companies do and so
um our team is using the latest science
and technology to deliver better
products to farmers that will help them
grow healthy
safe and affordable food sustainably and
i don't know if you guys have seen that
um
that book out there i it's um i believe
it highlights the 40 important decisions
that are made
every season so we know that farmers
make a lot of tough decisions for every
growing season and every farm
even within farm is different so this
one size fits all model that we used to
really operate on just doesn't work
so one thing that's clear here and it's
highlighted is that
farmers want to grow the best seed
varieties minimize
pests diseases and weeds in a way that
will balance societal
economic and environmental needs
the farmers really require solutions
that are going to go beyond a single
product
so we develop these tailored solutions
that will address the farmers individual
needs and challenges
the tailored solutions as you can see
in the diagram to the right it really
incorporates
high quality seeds and traits chemical
and biological crop production
protection products and digital farming
solutions
this approach also contributes to
efficiency and sustainability of knowing
precise timing and quantities of inputs
for subsets of fields
and ultimately improving yield while
saving
saving costs and resources
so our clear focus on r d has led us to
assembling the world's premier
innovation platforms in agriculture so i
think you guys will appreciate this
um if you start with the idea that plant
germplasm
and breeding is where we begin to look
for answers to farmers challenges each
of the additional platforms
biotech chemistry biologicals and data
science
they build upon that base we use our
leading germplasm library to begin that
process and then protect our
um really protect or enhance that
yield with biotechnology traits our uh
our reach of
um 350 million acres a year is really
unparalleled in that pursuit and we're
continuing
to build upon it with more than 20 next
generation
offerings and i think one of the cool
things about being in this discovery
space that i've kind of lived in for the
um last 30 sorry last three years um
is that there's this recognition of just
how much
hard work how much trying how much
failure
goes into identifying what these uh next
20
um 20 next generation offerings are as
well it sounds like a small number but
there's like thousands
of attempts that come before that um
so now kind of moving into this blue
section
uh we have a deep expertise in crop
protection
this includes a robust discovery
platform and a broad testing approach
to candidate molecules on top of that as
as with our focus in formulation
technology we really aim to have
the products last quite a long time
because it takes 14 years to develop
a new new molecule and um in addition to
the the formulation piece it takes about
that amount of time if
if not longer to develop some of the new
traits that we have coming out so
we really have to have quite a bit of
foresight and be intentional about um
these decisions that we're making in
in advance so if we look at the next
bubble here
um we add to uh
the crop the chemistry crop protection
the biological crop protection
and um here we're really screening more
than 10 000 micro
every year and those efforts ultimately
result in tens of billions of acres of
deployments in row crops alone
and that doesn't really highlight um the
foliar applications that are happening
in the horticulture
environment so uh this last piece
and the in the red is really uh data
science and it's a huge focus for our
company right now we're thinking about
our workforce segments and how to start
um
how to start uh building towards more of
a digital
capacity so it's critical because
this is the piece that's about providing
new insights both commercially
and in research for us to act upon so
um now on to a bit about the process
and i i really like having this
kind of having this understanding of the
um of the pipeline as a whole and i hope
that
um i hope that the the introduction that
we provide here can
can give you guys a little bit of
understanding of how we think about
our r d process um concepts for
commercial prod products are driven by
farmers needs and
inform native and biotech trait
discovery as well as precision breeding
efforts
candidate gene targets are identified
from a wide variety of sources including
those you guys out there
in the audience today are very familiar
with like genome mapping
association analyses and scientific
literature review
additionally we partner with external
discovery collaborators who are reliant
on our research focus
and provide strong candidates with
demonstrated activity
um and really it's these collaborators
are like providing the strong candidates
with demonstrated activity
in our crop of interest for um the
internal prioritization process that we
go through
so once we have a candidate gene
identified the next step is really to
choose the right tool and this is where
i think like you guys are going to just
love larry's talk as he can go into
a lot of detail and description around
this
uh breeding breeding traits
conventionally is
an important part of our seed business
and is currently the only
approach used in our vegetable business
but in the row crop business we have a
few key choices that we get
to take advantage of do we want to focus
in on transgenes
native traits or edits um the following
questions
really help us narrow those choices is
this gene
um native to the crop of interest so is
it is it in
the corn genome if if it is uh
external then we're going to have to
take that transgenic
route to introduce these unique unique
genetic traits but if it's internal
it really opens the door to genome
editing where we can create specific
genetic variation
or native traits to which we then ask
the
the following question because because
as you all know it's really important
that we have this natural variation
for genes of interest within
our germplasm set so if we if we have it
then it opens a possibility for
native trade exploration and once a
native trade donor is found in our
germplasm it can then be fed into the
pipeline
broader pipeline germplasm so if we
choose to go through the pipeline with
either transgenes or
edits the next critical step is um is to
design
is really the design of the vector or
the desired edit
should we choose to go the native trait
route we start a search and screen phase
to identify a germplasm that carries
that effective allele and then we
we work to integrate it so
um really once the uh allele or
transgene has been successfully
introduced into the plant
genome the edit proceeds through a
robust testing and selection process
which eventually
leads us to this phase one and two um
standpoint and this is
um really where i've lived in the last
uh last few years from that discovery
through
phase one space uh this is uh generally
where we
form what we call project teams to
ensure that we're working across
functions to evaluate the trait and
either advance through
additional phases or and this is
extremely important again
with that kind of like fail fast
component recommend a stop
uh make sure that we're not just sort of
like using these
resources to test some of our our
uh scientific hypotheses for example we
really need to make sure that we
we have good business intent behind them
so
uh this evaluation process is really
critical regardless of how the variation
is being introduced
be it edited native or transgenic trait
the process is focused on
characterization of the allele
as well as agronomic and molecular
assessments
and often initial characterization of
the trait is performed
in controlled environment for a first
look um but
then we do eventually move it out into
the field
and make sure that um we're really
following some of the most
critical stewardship guidelines
guidelines for testing in the field
because we want to make sure that
we we are being careful with
what's getting exposed in the into the
environment
so once we're in the field the allele
really needs to
meet performance criteria defined uh for
delivering that trade efficacy and and
that performance criteria is going to be
different it's kind of highlighted
in this slide but um it could be focused
from a
weed and pest standpoint but then they
could also have this
uh crop efficiency um focus and that's
thinking think things like
um yield or other sort of quality
traits so
um so really the intent here is that
once we're in the field it's not only
performing from the
from those um from that trade efficacy
standpoint but it's performing from an
overall agronomic performance standpoint
across representative geographies and
growing seasons
to really ensure that there aren't any
unintended phenotype
and that the desire trait performs
across environments and
importantly that when it does get
integrated into our germplasm
that we aren't seeing any kind of like
unintended um
yield hit with that because one thing
that we don't want to do is introduce
this
this new trait and then have the the
repercussions be
that it impacts our our breeding
germplasm long term
so if the allele continues to perform
we'll
initiate studies to describe the mode of
action of the trait to support the
product's
global regulatory reviews
all right um just a couple more slides
here before i hand it off to
to larry uh once we've evaluated and
selected for the final allele be it
native
transgenic or edited the next critical
step in the process is to integrate the
trait into
our elite germplasm pool there are
several
points in the breeding program where the
allele ventures can be interested
introduced for product development um
for
biotech treats and edits these are most
often introduced through trait
integration
and i talked about that in the intro
here ti's main focus is to take that
elite germplasm
coming from our line development
breeders and cross it in the new trait
using sequence and marker data
this process generally takes two to
three years and at the end we hand off
the new trait to supply chain for
commercial production
and to the commercial development
breeders for
more broad scale testing across our
network
a parallel path to breeding and ti the
new trait material
was also handed off to regulatory and
they're developing testing material to
generate data for submission packages to
agencies globally
then our last uh our last phase and
and man it's really exciting if
something can get this far
but the the main focus here is our three
um threefold regulatory is focused on
submissions and answering any questions
that need to be addressed from global
regulatory agencies
our supply chain organization is focused
on commercial seed production and
planning
and lastly mark development group is
doing further testing to better
understand our product and
define the the specific placement for
our products
and oftentimes um and this is something
that i learned when i when i got on
board was
that this happens in conjunction with
university extension collaborators so
there are
like these pre-existing or not
pre-existing intentional
um i would say collaborate
collaborations that are happening across
the
r d pipeline um with our universities
i would say most i would say probably
most heavily weighted on either end in
the very beginning within the discovery
space and then
towards the the very end um within the
the market dev space so with that um now
on to larry for more detail about gene
editing in crops and larry um i'll i'm
happy to advance just let me know
when to shift to the next slide i'm
gonna let's see i'm gonna try to share
my screen
um all right well thank you everybody
thank you
jackie and thank you rebecca for
inviting jackie who invited me it's a
great pleasure to be here and i'll
drill down in a little bit more detail
into one specific aspect of the science
that we do
uh specifically gene editing and we'll
try to save time for questions i'll talk
about the science of gene editing but
then also talk about the importance of
communication and engagement
which i did not appreciate as a graduate
student uh but i certainly appreciate
now
all right so first my backstory is uh
you know
a long time ago back in another
millennium i
got out of the navy saved up money for
college and said you know i want to go
to medical school i want to be a doctor
so as a biology major
and to improve my chances of getting
accepted into medical school i started
doing research in an undergraduate lab
at iowa
that's me on the left my very first
picture that i sent to my mother with my
lab coat on so she could be proud of me
but what happened during that
undergraduate experience
was i got hooked on basic research not
that basic research doesn't happen in
medicine but i got hooked on basic
biological research when i saw my first
yeast mutant that changed the pattern of
dna repair
and i thought this is great this is what
i want to do for the rest of my life
and so i changed my plan instead of
going to medical school i went to
graduate school
and that's me in oregon working on my
phd
and i was studying meiotic recombination
in
yeast so you know meiosis myotic
recombination is pretty interesting it
gave rise to pretty much everything that
we eat through improvements in plants
and animals and as you can tell if you
take a genetic approach to this you need
a lot of data points so there i am
standing there next to a wall of petri
plates
of yeast crosses that i had been making
painstakingly
and and that's what my dissertation was
and i used that then
to go off to study more of this
like like a lot of you when i was about
halfway through my phd program i was
wondering
what's next for me and i up until that
point i was thinking i definitely want
to get my own lab i want to
be a professor and then i started
hearing
even out in eugene oregon about possible
career paths
in um in in industry and so
on kind of a whim i took a position as a
postdoc
at monsanto company which was back then
we had a lot of postdoc
programs and i went into it thinking you
know i'm not going to like this
industry scientists they don't work as
hard they're they don't care as much
things like that and i got there and
within about two weeks i was converted
because i was working in the lab
alongside a lot of other scientists
who definitely cared as much definitely
worked just as hard
uh and definitely were just as creative
so i ended up
staying at monsanto which is now bayer
and um
this is a picture of me in huxley iowa
in a soy breeding field so i thought it
was appropriate to wear a meiosis shirt
in a soy breeding field
and a few minutes ago before we started
today i thought hey i still have that
shirt
and so i put it on so i'm not a breeder
i'm a molecular biologist i work in
biotechnology and have my entire career
and but i appreciate how biotechnology
and especially gene editing and breeding
can interface i've spent my entire
career
working on enabling technology where
whereas uh
jackie and others are focused on the
products that we're going to make
with these technologies in addition to
technology itself
my job has pretty much always been to
develop
the enabling technologies themselves
starting from things like how do you
what's the best way to put genes
together into a vector what's the best
way to deliver them into plant cells
what's the best way to generate plants
out of those
what's the best way to express the genes
best way to silence the genes
recombine the genes and genomes and now
more recently
what's the best way to do gene editing
so i've always worked on those tools
those methods those enabling
technologies
and i consider it basic research so if
people are wondering do companies big
companies do basic research
we absolutely do and that's what i've
spent most of my career on
and i couldn't be happier just like that
feeling i got when i saw that first
mutant in yeast when i was an undergrad
i feel that all the time so jackie did a
pretty good job of talking about the
uh interface between biotechnology so on
this slide represented by transgenes
native traits breeding and where genome
editing fits into that and
sometimes we take a biotech approach to
actually making gene edits
but i see it as the interface and if
anything
more like reading than biotechnology now
usually at some point in a talk like
this somebody will say i probably don't
have to tell an
audience like this uh how gene editing
works and then they tell you anyway
but i won't do that i'm sure by now
everybody knows how crisper specifically
works but i do want to talk about
how we use it because a couple of ways
may be a little bit different than what
most people think of when they think of
gene editing
when most people think gene editing they
think about the picture on the left
which is you you've got your nuclease
your scissors and you use it to
knock out genes or maybe make
substitutions
or changes in and around a gene itself
and that's great and we're doing that uh
we're definitely working on
uh applications of that but we also
think about it as an opportunity and
this is where plant
gene editing and agriculture gene
editing really differs from human
therapeutic uses
where we're a breeding company and so if
this can be used
to help with breeding that's great so
you can imagine
recombinations some types of
recombination anyway crossovers they
start with double strand breaks and
these enzymes make double strand breaks
so you can imagine
using this in ways that really really do
look like breeding
and then finally even though it's not
technically what i would call gene
editing
inserting trans genes we continue to
have a lot of really great trans genes
that we want to test and then develop
products on
but we want to be able to be more
precise in how we insert those in the
genomes
and so another use of these crispr tools
is to be able to target genes to
specific
locations and so all of that technology
all those
applications of using tools like crispr
are within scope of our enabling
technology development
and so when we think about how we work
on gene editing
in bayer we think about first being able
to discover
the gene targets themselves so i'm
focusing on the tools and methods but of
course they're they're useless without
having the right gene targets and this
is actually
the hardest part about gene editing is
knowing which genes to edit
and how to edit them to get the desired
trait so
we spent a lot of effort on that all the
way from the data science to the actual
tests in the in the lab
trust trying to figure out the right
targets and then how to edit them
we also spent a lot of time as i said
this is my job is developing the tools
and the methods to be able to do those
and finally you can certainly appreciate
uh
that being able to make the edit in one
plant
doesn't really get you to an actual
product since we sell hundreds of
hybrids
in corn for example so the one of the
biggest challenges we have is how do we
get that edit
into all of those different germplasms
somehow my slides are auto advancing
sorry um where we are right now for the
most part
in in our editing is trying using edits
to make traits and this is where
jackie and i are teaming up most of the
uh especially now
um is how do we actually use the edits
to make traits specific genes specific
traits
um where we're moving to is thinking
about it is more the learning tool
and learning about the genes and about
the genomes so that then we can learn
more about
the gene targets and how do we edit them
how do we edit those to make traits
where i see this going in the future
is really thinking about it more and
more as a breeding tool
maybe maybe editing to breed might be a
little bit of an exaggeration but i'm
definitely seeing this as a
really important part of breeding in the
future especially when you think about
things like swapping arms of chromosomes
and so on
i'm just going to give a few quick
examples of editing projects that we
have
going on now and then i'll move into the
communication part
so this is actually published work you
may have seen this but this
we're really interested in short stature
corn semi dwarf corn
um doing for corn what has been done for
crops like rice and wheat in the green
revolution
and so you can imagine ways that you
might be able to do that
it's known that auxin and auxin
transport plays a role in inter
internode distance
or length uh and so you can think about
targeting genes like the bracketic 2
gene
that work in that pathway uh and then
giving hopefully a desired phenotype a
shorter stature
um corn plant and so you can see in the
image on the right
a a wild type allele bracket two and the
image in the
let's see the middle now the left is a
native
transposon insertion and ltr
retrotransposon insertion that
inactivates the gene
and so then what we did was we used cas9
to make
a an indel in one of the again my slides
are advanced
uh and indel in one of the exons that
knocked out the gene as well and
basically
uh made a phenocopy of that transposon
insertion
and so this is a good example of how a
loss of function of a gene can actually
lead
to a desirable trait
as i said we're interested in uh using
this technology to
um to to be able to position the
insertion of
genes uh trans genes specifically and
one way you can do that is by making
double strand breaks its specific loci
and then the genes will at a low
frequency insert there so
here's an experiment where we were
preparing to do that in soybean
and we wanted to test lots and lots of
specific positions
so 15 different locations in the genome
but multiple potential sites at each of
those locations
so this ended up becoming a pretty big
experiment testing out about
191 of these and so we learned a lot
about gene editing in general
for this like the frequency of getting
uh
edits at a wide range of sites we were
able to see
deletions where if we uh
design guidelines for two different
target sites that were close together
sometimes
we would see deletions there and at a
lower frequency
we would even see inversions where the
piece would cut out actually flip
and then insert back in so while this
project had a specific
aim in in mind to insert transients
eventually
we learned a lot about uh just editing
in general from this project
and then finally a couple other uh quick
highlights of work that's been going on
my team you can do editing in a variety
of ways by delivering
the re the genes the editing machinery
through agrobacterium
you can deliver them by particle gun
transformation you can also deliver them
directly to protoplasts
and those of you who have worked with
protoplast know that in general it's not
easy to generate
fertile plants from protoplasm but it
can be done with enough skill
and in certain crop species it may be a
little bit easier to do so in canola
we've been able to do editing
in a dna free wave just by delivering
the
ribonucleic protein complexes the rnp's
directly to the protoplast getting the
edit at the desired location
and then regenerating a fertile plant
from that
finally pretty much everything i've been
talking about so far is
making indels or deletions basically
cutting a
point in the genome and then having it
repair
uh through non-homologous end joining we
also want to be able to make
replacements
and so we've had some success by
delivering not only the rp
but a single stranded oligonucleotide in
this case targeting a gene called tawny
in soybean and taught the
most um cultivated soybean has a
frameshift mutation
in there that changes the phenotype of
the seed pod
and by going in there and repairing that
frameshift we've been able
using this templated oligo uh approach
we've been able to
change that phenotype
all right um you know there's a lot of
excitement
about gene editing or in everything but
including in agriculture and there's
actually a fair amount of hype about
gene editing
uh one thing that you'll hear a bit
about is that it can really accelerate
the development of improved crops
in fact you'll hear some people say we
can go from the lab to the field
in one week one in less than a year
which
while that's true that's not the same
thing as actually making products that
that will end up on farmers fields
because there's still a lot of work that
has to happen you have to make
the edits you have to recover those
plants you have to test and validate
them
you have to then bulk those up and go
through the ti process that jackie
talked about and you still do have to
review this with regulatory agencies
so it does take time it has the
potential to be faster
uh but not as fast as as some might
think
so i want to now try to wrap up in the
last few minutes here by talking about
some of the non-technical aspects
about gene editing so i've been in the
company and working in the industry for
over 25 years
mostly on gmos and so i've had a direct
view of some of the challenges
associated with gmos and so the question
is what's going to happen with gene
editing and so
as this started to grow this field
started to grow a few years ago
i personally became very interested in
all
aspects of making this successful
regulatory acceptance success and public
acceptance success the landscape for
regulatory policy and gene editing is
still evolving
so in the u.s gene edits are viewed a
lot like
um variants derived from breeding but in
other parts of the world
and especially in europe it's still
viewed very much like a gmo
and then other parts of the world are
still deciding or somewhere in between
so that's the regulatory landscape but
then there's also
the the sort of the public perception on
this
and again having myself been
involved in the development of
genetically modified organisms biotech
traits and seeing some of the challenges
there
we can reflect back on what we can learn
from that experience
and think about how we can apply those
that learning
to gene editing and one thing for sure
is we definitely want to engage more
and be more part of the conversation not
just with the growers and the farmers
themselves
but with everybody including the food
chain the value chain
including the consumers and so that's
a different approach that we're taking
now with gene editing and i personally
get involved in this
uh through a lot of engagement so the
last thing i want to mention as i wrap
up here is to encourage all of you
grad students undergrads uh post docs
many of you are already doing this
certainly more than when i was in grad
school but it really really is
important to engage and talk about the
science you're doing
share the passion that you have about
the science
it's fun and and it's important because
the coolest technologies in the world
the best science in the world like all
these
great things that we can do with with
gene editing
don't matter if the world isn't ready
for it
or if they don't want it or if they
don't understand it and so
i personally spend a lot of time on this
i enjoy it a lot i've got my colorful
needs there
um but i i encourage you to think about
that too
and uh if you aren't already thinking
about the importance of
community um engagement please do this
is really important
as important as the science that's the
key learning for me it took me
20 years to figure that out but it is
really important
so that was fast sorry about that but i
just wanted to
see if we could save a little bit of
time for questions
thank you so much to both of our
presenters
that was terrific um let me open the
floor
we have a few questions here um
uh are the results uh or christian you
want to go ahead with your question
um sure i was just curious you mentioned
the basic research that industry does
and
i was just curious how much of that is
available publicly um
yeah versus proprietary and sort of i
know um because
we're talking about the importance of
the economics of it making sure that it
carries a viability for the company too
yeah
i was just answering your your question
in the chat there and actually um how to
leverage a couple of life lines over
here
um to to help support the the answer but
um from what i hear from some of the
scientists coming in it sounds like um
we've recently released genomic
uh sequence data one for the um genome
of soybean cyst nematode and for
asian soy rust uh recently um and
and uh a lot as for uh developing the
products i
i think in one of the slides that had
highlighted this mode of action
um process that we go through for
regulatory purposes
uh but but what's done uh with that data
generally is that um it's
it's patented and then um published uh
so that way people
have um access to that um more more
broadly
i think um those are the the primary
ones uh that come to my mind larry um
that's on your end yeah so
the basic research is done we do publish
um you can if you haven't done it
already you can look us up and see
we don't publish as much as an academia
um and then patents are eventually
published too so there's actually a lot
of data in those as well
and we go out and give a lot of talks um
could we be better at it yes for sure
um but we it's most of the results of
basic research
will eventually be publicly available so
speaking of giving talks i did want to
thank you both not only for the great
technical aspects of your talk but also
for the personal side which i also
really appreciate it
um ellie would you mind going ahead with
your your question
yeah thanks rebecca um so larry thank
you i really enjoyed your talk
i'm also fascinated by meiosis and its
potential
um to use editing as like a breeding
tool
like sometimes it's referred to as
controlled recombination
to basically induce double stranded
breaks where you want them
and you also actually mentioned that a
lot of
like as someone who's on the cutting
edge of developing tools
the timeline from getting them from labs
to fields
can be long and curious with your
expertise
if you could speak to how likely you
think that transfer
from labs to fields is for a tool like
controlling recombination
um or if it would happen during our
careers hopefully
great question ellie and yeah i think
about this a lot
my um my phd dissertation was the role
of double strand breaks and biotic
recombination
in east um anyway so this will
definitely happen
in your career
i don't know about mine um but so i
guess
um my first thought was make a double
string break the correct and especially
if you do it in meiosis
that you'll see basically recombination
as you know it's
not that simple it's more to it than
just a double strand break you're
probably familiar with the work from
vulgar pupda
who's actually been doing this long
before anybody even knew what crispr was
with megan nucleases and talons and so
on
so i do believe that a double strand
break
will be an important part of it but it's
not the only part
and because it's not the only part it'll
probably take a little longer
to do this but eventually i believe that
we'll be able to make targeted
recombination
where we want that's that's encouraging
thank you
okay over to you ed well i guess
this requires that targeted
recombination uh
but you mentioned translocations and i
was
actually wondering if you you know with
a few translocations
uh you can pretty much isolate a species
from any other species
and you know actually i did my phd a
little bit on one where
a genera a genus that do that all the
time are you all thinking about making
your own germplasm pools that are
essentially genetically isolated with a
bunch of translocations
you know you know that's a great
question i should tell you that i have
two business cards
one of them is my boring title and the
other one is genome futurist and i
which card i give out depends on who i'm
talking to if i were talking to you
in person i'd hand you that genome
futurist card that being said
no we're not thinking about making our
own translocations to have our own
varieties
that can't be intermingled certainly i
can understand
how that could work but we are
you know still working in the broad
germplasm that we have which
has ten chromosomes and so um
not currently uh focus area for us but i
i like i like the way of thinking
uh next up anna susan hermans please
um hi thanks for the wonderful talk um
so i was wondering um
with respect to your introduction about
like the growing world population
and needing more food to feed the
growing world population
i was wondering i mean mostly because
you talked about i guess feed corn
and canola i saw you also had vegetables
on one of your slides
do you have any information on how
on a larger scale i guess your results
impact
or support that goal of growth of um
feeding the population or is that still
is your work still
like that too early shoes to give any
um like a long-term impact yeah so i'm
sure
i'm sure larry has um some thoughts on
this but um one thing that i was most
excited about with regards to
gene editing is that it it doesn't cost
us as much
to to um develop these traits as as
we've started to model things out
and so there's been a lot more interest
in focusing on
some of the some of the smaller
markets um that that could
that could potentially allow us to focus
in on specific
like quality traits uh that that the
consumers are interested in
and so um i think that that that's
an avenue that we're exploring more and
more um
and then uh in addition i know i focused
on on corn
that's that's a lot of where i spend my
energy but
in addition to the row crops we do have
this whole
vegetable organization that's uh that's
focused more broadly
but i just also want to add that one of
the um one of the things that i've
been most excited about coming on board
with bayer
is that they have a broader focus
than what monsanto did when it card
comes to global small holder
farmers and and so we have this focus on
pest and drought resistant plants that
really
will should increase uh yield for
smallholder farmers and i think that
there's just
more interest in developing our programs
to take our crops to
uh the markets the markets in particular
in western
western and eastern africa wow cool
uh arcadio
um hi there thank you both for your uh
talks
uh i was wondering wanted to ask you
guys if uh
thinking of innovation at bayer if you
guys are aware of or if
bayer is sort of like considering the
whole shifting production
for uh alternative protein sources for
people
i'm waiting to see if jackie's gonna
have yeah my i
oh sorry i didn't mean i didn't mean for
my camera to go off there
my my head was definitely nodding
um so i i highlighted some of the the
crop
team um some of the the fact that we
have this crop team that's focused on
building strategies and
and like a lot of um of companies that
are out there
more broadly we've also come upon the
the need to focus on
um soybean uh protein from multiple
aspects um so what we've done is derived
really
uh four primary market targets that um
interested
in going after and um we're we're
pursuing that
actively but i would say that's largely
in discovery right now
okay great so i want to give the i've
noticed that we're running out of time
in fact we're already
uh a bit over but julia can you please
give us the last question
uh thanks rebecca um thank you both so
much for your talk i mean i think
these company talks are very much
inspiring like just the the
the the thought process that goes into
giving a customer value
is amazing um so then i i
my little my two long text is about
moral hazard and the classic example of
a tobacco company that knows full well
there's a relationship between tobacco
and cancer and yet hides it
and you know at the end contrary to this
i think a lot of your talk
showed that there's quite a bit of
alignment between the public good
and montanto's you know company goals
but i can't imagine that that's a
hundred percent of the time the case
and you know it's something that what
i'm curious about in terms of being part
of a company is how do you think about
okay when might there not be an
alignment between shareholder profit
and uh and um
the public good however and and how do
you
what what space do you have to think
about that
how do you go about those questions
i don't know if that makes sense but
that's my my thought
yeah i mean that makes sense again i
think i want to give larry some time to
to answer here
um as well but i just want to say that
we were one of their montana was one of
the first companies that
that came on to market with um
transgenics and
and we were also the ones that um really
held ourselves accountable because there
was no
kind of regulatory um guidelines with
how to how to move that cell forward uh
forward and so
um we've we've really um i would say
kind of
pave the path for making sure that we're
doing the right science to
to assume that or the right signs to
make sure that we're not
introducing any kind of um allergens or
or toxins into the food that we're
producing and then
similarly um similarly making sure that
what we are
generating especially from the season
traits and that's where i'm you know
where i'm most familiar with
um is um this was on par
with the the non-transgenic um
uh uh material so we set up experiments
for that purpose and
really that's the only way that it gets
through the regulatory bodies this way
is that it's
it's safe from a human consumption
standpoint
larry since we're short on time i'll
just say you know we're people too
we're corporate scientists but we're
also people jackie's a mom i'm a dad
and i think that's what we use as our
compass
um and i certainly don't i think we have
complete space
to think about potential moral hazards
so i saw my own hand go up and i just
want to wedge on i promise that was only
was gonna be the last but if you're
thinking of that question in the in the
sort of
crop protection zone of your graph
jackie
you know you've got the you have the
chemistry and then you have the
biologicals and then you know of course
there's
there's the plant genetic approaches as
well for crop protection and so i'm sort
of wondering like
is the company able or willing to do
anything to sort of
you know put itself out there a bit to
move more
dependency into you know out of the
chemistry and into the biological and
biological and biological host versus
microbial biological
and that shows my kind of anti-chemistry
mindset which
um you know which i think is not
completely unfounded
but i feel like unless the company sort
of um
put them you know put their their hearts
into making that [ __ ] they're not so
sure how it's going to get done
so any do you see any sign of the of of
the company sort of
maybe choosing to push harder to move
their
portfolios out of that chemistry space i
mean i can
i can i think i can say this larry since
i've been at the company
there was not a um biologics program
when i first joined that i'm aware of
and um
my understanding is that the the small
molecules um
or the the biologics program um is
actually
more substantial now that we're with
bear than what it was before
larry do you have a sense of how that's
changed over time as well
no i mean bayer bayer has a lot of
chemistry a lot of small molecules
i think i'd go back just the tailored
solution i think
the best combination of the best tools
we need every tool i know it sounds
cliche but we really really do need
every tool in the toolbox and they need
to be safe and they need to be
sustainable and so on
but i don't think we would rule out
anything as long as it
can meet the needs of the growers and be
done safely
and so um i i'm personally interested in
the genetics
of course um but i think there's there's
some
room for any kind of tool that can help
well we don't have any more questions on
the list
and we're gone over time and i just
really want to again um
ask everyone to join me in thanking our
speakers for a tripping seminar thanks
so much
welcome back jackie um thank you for
being back virtually
please be back here you know we need to
see some next generation talent
two-year-old category so
thank you so much rebecca thank you
larry all right thanks hi everybody
thank
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu